welcome to this video for round three of
the joshimath memoria from shonky
Azerbaijan round three yow he had two
rounds already with the magnus carlsen
being the winner and it was pretty
logical that I am covered Carlton's
games from the first rounds and
thankfully this time we can look at yeah
thankfully is the wrong word I mean I
joy looking at at girls games but it's
always good to have some variety so this
time I'll be looking at the game
Nakamura mamedyarov as my game of the
day from this tournament the two other
games ended in draws and the Nakamura
manager of game probably was the most
interesting one it's not a given that I
will cover the decisive result if there
is only one decisive result I'm kind of
giving it a way that this game is not
ending in a draw but okay that's not so
important as long as I don't spoil it
all together as I spawn it all together
okay so the other two games are a job of
kawana as mentioned a draw it was a long
theoretical duel in the exchange group
fraught with rugby one we can look at it
very briefly just that you know what I'm
talking about with some some uncommon
move all that we've got the goon felt on
the board and check they played this
very well-known sharp line and it seems
it was a pretty much a preparation war
this is well known and I think it
continued the long known lines but it is
some another expert but I think the
general verdict is that this should end
in a draw anyway just a matter of watch
lie what line is chosen while it ended
in a pipette
or some sort of repetition I'm not quite
sure how exactly it went down okay look
I've said no one if to check check check
yeah we had to the repetition um yeah I
didn't look at this game too much also
not during the broadcast simply am most
of that had been prepared at home the
game kayak in cars was a different
affair it was a long game 60-year
something about 60 moves wear gowns and
help the advantage for quite quite some
time out of an Enzo we we had the very
closed position let's put it on the
board just hear this type of position um
which is really yeah very a very
maneuvering type of type of game but
okay I can open up the position with g5
and still the general problem at issue
is that long-term those pawns can be a
problem and the way it was played here
White had very little dynamism to show
it it came to a situation where an S you
seem I'm scrolling quickly a.m. to move
27 situation where you got an endgame
white having the bishop pair but bishops
are not so terribly effective here and
black having the long-term plan of
attacking the weekend pawns in addition
coyoacán was done on time however he
made the time control i don't think that
clock times yeah totally correct at the
end i think he only had one or two
seconds left it was really a close call
but we got an end game where if the
commentators are correct magnus could
have won at one or two spots but didn't
manage
at the end of it ended in a draw so on I
want to go through it any longer it was
really this kind of tough maneuvering
well there was some little thing that
Magnus miss to win the game so he could
have been on three out of three but
let's now go to the the main cause of
this video Nakamura Mammadyarov yeah um
yeah both players have suffered defeats
at the hands of Magnus in round one and
round two so certainly they both would
like to win the game to get back into
the tournament back on fifty percent and
let's see what opening we get the
caricom slight surprise mamedyarov is
not a regular caricom player he played
the Sicilian in the candidates
tournament just a few weeks ago and c6
is not one of his main weapons but I had
a look at the database and it seems that
he had played quite a number of caricom
games in blitz and rapid events in 2013
so it's not like he has never ever
played it but certainly am at least a
small surprise for nakamura okay we had
the advanced variation of the cal cal
and nakamura is going for the modern
main line of the CARICOM the short
system with 93 and time Bishop with you
I really mean that that's the main line
of the whole opening nowadays what is
blacks set up here there are a number of
ways that black can set up his pieces
one problem that black am always faces
is that what it is certainly
strategically desirable to have the
bishop out of the pawn chain I mean this
is very much like a French defense in
the center but of course black has the
bishop on f5
here out of the paunch instead of c-5
the problem however is that compared to
the French you need two moves to get in
c 5 so this loses a move compared to the
French and the second loss of the tempo
compared to French's well the bishop 1a5
so the counter play in the center is
coming just a lot slower than in the
French defence and this is why black
must be very cautious with quick opening
of the position so if he plays c5 which
is now played by Mammadyarov he must be
very alert that this is not blowing up
into his face with the position opening
up quickly one one other problem is the
bishop on f5 is not helping in defending
the queenside so white sometimes can
open up the position quickly with c4
sometimes those checks and so on
therefore black very often does not play
c5 but develops first with moves like 97
97 h6 Bishop 87 Knight to c8 yeah this
kind of fear moved pieces first and only
later break with c5 has become very
popular and in fact in those games that
Mammadyarov had played in the last year
he always had played 97 okay but this
time is going for a c5 the sharp move on
Bishop e3 very important that's far more
dangerous than castles one point is that
white sometimes really very quickly
wants to open up the position with c4
and therefore you shouldn't even ways to
move with castling there should be three
Queen to be six this is the absolutely
sharples line that black can play
directly attacking would be to point
yeah of course in many openings black as
is on the hunt grabbing the ball on b2
and in almost all of those openings the
best responses to ignore it in one way
or another and here that's exactly the
same Knight c3 plata by nakamura he just
ignores the threat on the b2 pond um of
course that's not a new mooses has been
played really a number of times mahmoud
yarrow smooth now is maybe a slight
surprise he played Knight to c6 it is a
slight surprise because despite being
well-known print xb2 is still probably
the main move here and it is quite funny
because after Queen takes be too at
first you think that night b5 should be
very strong threatening to win the rook
yeah the funny thing is that this night
be five move is a much less dangerous
than you would think at first black has
the very nice reply c4 quite a quite a
funny idea the idea is that now night c7
King be 798 Bishop takes e2 is not at
all great for white the whole situation
is is really am yeah not very attractive
so yeah the thing is this night White
has an extra ruka at the moment but this
night will not escape like will will
gain it will win it at the end and then
you have at least those two pawns and
very very tricky position think about
this type of condition for example how
is white going to untangle that it's not
easy at all therefore night b5 isn't
really the move White has a stronger
move available after Queen takes be too
and it's oops this funny move going to
be one quite remarkable what is the
exact point yeah
the night is hanging on c3 but like
takes it there is Bishop g2 and now
black has a huge problem when the Queen
away there is Queen B 7 and now we have
the rope hanging and Quincy ate both
moves very very dangerous so why this
right is totally Winningham black cannot
take the nod yeah what else is there
like an exchange but after Luke takes be
one there is still this idea and this
route b7 and both them cannot be
defended this is also good for white so
what exactly is blacks move yeah it
seems that the latest and interesting
try is Queen to b4 here and after that a
recent game went a three Queen a five
and now detects e5 and e6 the funny
point is why white can never take care
because this is this is too much winning
or with check and black now will really
return with the Queen after having gone
fishing so to say like this Henry chance
all the way back to to c7 and has a
decent position this has been played at
a game between Z galco and only shook
just in 2014 a recent game on yeah this
seems to be the in the main the main
line in a way in at the mode um the n96
was played by mamedyarov um it seems
that this is less less common but still
playable to be honest I don't like it
very much because the upcoming sequence
is very forced and I don't really think
that blacks position is so comfortable I
mean it's not like it is totally bad but
if you ask me I wouldn't go for that
really liked it and I'll show you why 96
um yeah well white took it on c5 Bishop
takes c5 and Bishop takes d5 it's always
important to check this move but Queen a
5s more than sufficient to give like a
good game so the capture Queen takes and
95 and this is exactly the problem with
the blacks um yeah with Lex set up here
blacks idea not a problem that is
leading to to a loss but I think it
looks quite uncomfortable there is 97 of
course this threat and also 96 so black
must react to that you cannot play a
natural move like let's say rook c8 as
96 as mentioned is also coming there is
only this move the only one available to
make sure that both threads are our met
adequately yeah but while this isn't
very nice with the King on evade how
exactly are you going to get your ruca
Jaden to play this is not the end of the
world for black but I'm not quite sure
why black yeah when Mammadyarov was
compelled to to go for that I mean Raimi
spent 15 minutes not like and how or so
he didn't let's say from forget as
preparation and had to reinvent it all
over the board it must be some sort of
preparation but why would you go for
that just deliberately not quite sure
but ok as mentioned it's not lost for
black or even clearly worse it just
feels very uncomfortable um ok let's see
what happened very normal moves here we
should form Andrew p1 all this looks
totally normal yeah and here in this
position
Mammadyarov plays the first new move I
doubt that this was part of the
preparation but he technically plays a
novelty here playing Queen to before and
yeah well well the computer I'd say if
it still thinks that this is okay for
black I don't like it very much but it's
not it's not easy for black two to play
here the move Queen before really has
the idea to grab one B two words just
like that it's very very crude in a way
um yeah I personally would have tried to
sort of get the rook into play on a jade
it's not easy to do but yeah at least I
think you should try um there's been a
game here from two games actually with
h6 c3 Queen B 6 b 3 rook c8 for example
the idea being to get the king over to
age 7 and then connect rocks this has
been played for example and again
between again cigar co and Maxime tore
off from 2010 and I I just think how
black it is still slightly uncomfortable
but at least you have chances to to get
your hooks connected quickly another
idea and this is the suggestion of them
of Houdini the engine is to play h5 here
which really wouldn't have occurred to
me but it is so there is a point I mean
black has this idea maybe activating the
rook of course you can sometimes there
are cases where you can activate look
like that and then at the end you
recognize it is not doing so much on its
own on the King side it is however
interesting it's not totally totally
crazy idea yellow media off went for
Queen before and after a three which is
really a guest sort of provoking the
capture he took on me to Luke be one
Queen a three Andrew p7 this was arising
almost by force after Queen before and
well I think it's just a bit
uncomfortable why would you invite the
route to be seven I mean this is just a
very strong piece on b7 and I just think
that the other set up let's say with age
six it felt much more much more solid
but okay this is a very em let's a
general way to think about chassis just
calculated things and it's it's not our
concrete calculation always trums
general considerations but it does not
feel right to me very much to invite the
rukon on b7 yeah me dr off north took on
a three and played h6 now yeah the h6
move here has two ideas i guess to this
this king of travel to age seven however
they will very often be a bishop or
queen on d3 another idea certainty is
also to prevent a night move to g5 yeah
after age 60 come where up late Queen to
d2 yeah that's a fine move there also
was see for this is what what i actually
had expected during the broadcast but it
also has drawbacks c4 looks like a good
aggressive move and it probably is okay
um what did but what it also does is on
see to it is a natural uncie to the pawn
provides natural cover for the bishop on
d3 for example our piece coming to d3 so
when there are some advantages on having
the pawn on on c2 yeah Queen d2
as mentioned yeah now I think the next
move by Mammadyarov really really puts
them into trouble I mean around here um
it's probably still okay it feels a bit
tricky to play but it's all should be
should be a perfectly acceptable
position he now played the move g5 and
this is not it seems that this is not
really working out too well for black
the possible alternative would have been
a queen a5 trying to get the Queen's off
or maybe look to be eight yeah both both
are interesting trying to get rid of the
queen or trying to get rid of the dc-7
rook which is always very annoying on
the seventh after that white certainly
has compensation but it is much better I
think than the game after g5 yeah the
natural normal response was age for who
I am buying Minako yeah and our g5 hangs
yeah so black can only play d4 and now
very strong move planned beforehand um
94 that's very very important that this
is possible and the important thing is
well what happens if black grabs upon
yeah it's a seems that this move is
entirely unplayable because of Queen to
f4 and that's just very very strong this
is hanging and there is 96 threatening
it's just totally lost now black has no
move whatsoever this is the relatively
toughest but then I can just move the
rook away from the attack and again
there is 96 their screen takes yeah and
to all I mean you can move the Queen you
either the night and then this one is
totally killing also groupie aid of
course
so black cannot take on e5 event queen
85 now and now again a very strong
response c3 my personal opinion about
this g5 movies I mean it's very often
maybe the top players they then see that
this is a weakening move but they rely
on concrete calculation and it is
possible that exactly in the way the
game went let's say for example here
that mamedyarov made some sort of wrong
calculation regarding for example I'm
just speculating here regarding let's
say Knight takes d5 for example this is
not a playable move but maybe beforehand
he thought that he could take it and
only later recognized it was not working
possible just speculation all night XD 5
it's relatively easy for such a good
player to see that a move like bishop f1
or Bishop b5 they're both good leads to
two enormous travel food like the
problem is well the knight on d5 is
hanging and if you move from this for
example like this White has the very
strongly group takes c6 yeah and this is
completely killing black yeah the
captures even a check mate check in two
moves now so black cannot take and white
has numerous ideas Queen f4 being that
we are probably the most ND one black is
completely completely lost so we cannot
take on e5 really due to this most
others so we went night XD form twin txt
for and now night f5
yeah Queen went back to d2 white is
still pretty much forced to play a very
precisely if you take on g4 for example
there is Queen takes c3 end this is a
very inconvenient double attack this is
stronger it keeps ac3 on the board g4 is
still hanging and the Queen sometimes
later can go to f4 or to h6 if
circumstances of our right for that yeah
d4 was played and now Bishop takes g4
yeah could have like a covered the G
porn yeah we can look at age five but
after Bishop d3 it is very tough for
black white is just threatening to take
on a five and after that enter with the
Queen or taking a t6 is also very strong
black now I'm it's already almost forced
to give away huge chunks of material
most likely apiece if you retreat for
example Queen g5 attacking here okay it
Queen f6 I'm just putting a sample line
on the board to illustrate the dangers
get your black will resign probably it's
just an enormous attack well d4 was was
tried by by Mammadyarov Bishop takes
Queen takes on c3 and Queenie to of
course keeping the Queen's on with
blacks King position so insecure you
don't want to trade yeah and white now
has a very direct threat Bishop takes on
f5 and Queen to h5 the right moment or
taking andy sixx ar e six the rock only
one is delaying so
you should be called they're cautious
with a queen age five but taking a t6 is
a very strong thread yeah in this
position there was only one move that
does not lose quickly and it was not
played by mamedyarov he could have gone
97 which is somewhat tougher after this
move White has a number of interesting
tries one is Queen to reform
centralizing the Queen and preparing
moves like Ruby seven or bishop age five
and then going on they have seven pawn
um yeah black can play Queen c6 for
example this is just one line to
illustrate the position it's not totally
forced on necessarily the absolute best
but it shows that white has so much
activity that the pawn deficit is very
easily compensated and why does some
even yeah far better in this position
King g7 and rook takes for example would
be f8 Bishop f3 it's now material
equality but well compared the bishop on
f3 to the night on d8 now Lex only hope
is the a porn but why term will probably
get this as well so it should be it
should be winning in any way but this
what was played by mama dr office it's
almost losing with the force made on
already Bishop age five yeah rook age
seven no real other way to to cover that
night g6 that's answered by the simple
capture and after the recapture there is
Queenie fall intending a quick mate and
blackheads says absolutely no way to
prevent it yeah this was played as
mentioned and now Queen to you for
attacking the rook attacking the night
and threatening to play a strong
discover check yeah and this is just too
much rook c8 was played if Black gets
trying to save the night here there is
Luke l7 check and now the very strong
moving rookie for 2g phone yeah and
black will get mated probably maybe you
can suck the Queen somehow but it 21
safe black in any case yeah rook c8 was
played and now knock i just calculated
this to the end taking on age 7 check
check allowing this but he had seen that
after this g3 move now black has
absolutely no reply um yeah black and
try for for some sort of perpetual with
with the night IAM but it does not help
at the end there's even just kingi too
yeah look at this it's a piece
checking g2s maybe even somewhat easier
as now black has absolutely no move yeah
this was played check check check again
the check yet after Queen f8 it seems
that Mammadyarov still played this move
but at the same time resins the game not
waiting for nakamura to play rook to be
five check and winning the Queen and the
wall made is not very far off i think
this is one of those cases if you give
give the computer enough time it will
show mate in 20 or something just just a
big king and yeah i really don't don't
like the black opening strategy that
much with King to have eight it's
probably not not terribly bad but it
just just does in my just my opinion um
it does not feel right to to to place
yeah to to set yourself this does this
problems it's black why exactly what you
do that I think that they're probably
should be all better lines available
that are easier to play I mean it's just
like probably you're okay but you need
to find so many precise moves that it is
tough to do maybe here with age six or
h5 this is some better defense he went
for this very concrete maneuver grabbing
on the queenside but after this after
this g5 idea I think black was in huge
trouble maybe in some way possible to a
to to hold it but not it's not really
nice to play and position also I might
add that it's very much certainly tuned
I cameras like it was a very good
dynamic attacking player so he certainly
does not mind to have black skin
position weekend and
have an attack all right so after three
rounds we see that of course Carlin is
the leading with plus two having won the
first two games followed by Nakamura on
fifty percent and with a win and loss
and if i'm not mistaken with job of Aunt
Clara wanna also on fifty percent with
withdraws plate um kayaking also should
have fifty percent if i'm not mistaken
yeah so we have a bunch of the players
on fifty percent only a Mammadyarov
really has a rockin tournament he has
lost two games and just a draw so really
not not a great start at all for the
number one player of azerbaijan alright
i hope you enjoyed the coverage of this
game i'll be back tomorrow with coverage
for Round four thanks for watching